dès le 1er janvier 2010 air c'est madame
la ministre la parole est à monsieur
yannick moreau ma question s'adresse au
premier ministre les bonnes intentions
réformatrice initiale sur le droit du
travail se sont vite évanouis sous les
pavés et la biodiversité des fumées de
la place de la république
malheureusement votre projet de loi ne
laisse plus beaucoup d'espoir de
simplification aux entrepreneurs de
notre pays qu'il est long avec votre
gouvernement
le chemin du projet à la chose avec
jérôme lambert et 27 collègues siégeant
sur tous les bancs nous avons proposé
d'améliorer votre texte ennui ajoutant
notre amendement molière mais vous avez
des idées leur emploi du 49 3 et donc la
fin du débat parlementaire en première
lecture à l'assemblée
fier que vous êtes de ce texte qui n'est
pourtant que l'ombre d'une réforme du
code du travail
vous refusez le débat et les
contributions des députés notre
abonnement aux molières qui sera déposé
au sénat puis à l'assemblée en deuxième
lecture est simple et de bon sens
il cherche à lutter contre les dérives
de la directive de 96 sur les
travailleurs détachés les plus courtes
erreur étant toujours les meilleurs
notre amendement molière transpose
l'initiative du collectif franc-parler
et vise à obliger les travailleurs
détachés à maîtriser le français ou les
entreprises qui les emploient à recourir
aux services d'un interprète
c'est d'abord une question de sécurité
sur les chantiers
c'est aussi une question de quitter pour
les artisans français du btp qui font
face à une concurrence assez largement
déloyale aggravée par les marchés
publics qui organise une course
permanente au moins disant social alors
que le parlement va débattre encore
quelques mois du code du travail nous
avons eu l'occasion de corriger
l'injustice congénitale introduite par
la directive bolkenstein de 1996
monsieur le premier ministre
allez vous oui ou non soutenir
l'amendement molière
répondez moi franchement monsieur le
premier ministre je veux qu'on soit
sincère
et quand un homme d'honneur on ne lâche
aucun mot qui ne partent du coeur merci
la parole d'état madame myriam el khomri
ministre du travail de l'emploi à la
formation professionnelle et du dialogue
social
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
yannick moreau ou là la caricature que
vous faites sur le projet de loi
et permettez moi de me revenir quelques
instants
je partage tout à fait l'objectif de
lutte contre la fraude au détachement je
crois essentiel dans cet hémicycle de
rappeler que ce qui est en jeu c'est à
la liberté de circulation des
travailleurs dans l'espace européen
d'ailleurs la france étant le troisième
pays d'envoi de travailleurs 1 dans
l'espace européen nous n'avons pas de
leçons à donner de ce point de vue là
mais ce qui est en jeu et vous l'avez
dit à juste titre ce qui est en jeu
c'est les fraudes
la lutte contre les fraudes au
détachement parce que elle elle mine à
la fois notre modèle social mais
également parce que c'est une
concurrence déloyale en direction des
employeurs
c'est pour cela que au delà des paroles
nous agissons nous agissons à la fois
avec un régime le plus strict avec la
loi savary avec la loi macro mais nous
agissons aux accents en mettant en
oeuvre de nombreux contrôles sur
l'ensemble du territoire mais nous
agissons au niveau européen justement
pour rectifier la directive de 96 ont
pas pris la moins fort je vais vous
répondre très précisément cet amendement
prévoyait en effet l'obligation pour un
travailleurs détachés de parler ou de
comprendre le français ou à défaut
obliger l'employeur à prévoir les
services d'un interprète
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
sur le fond la question de la langue
elle est essentielle notamment en termes
d'accès au droit ou pour comprendre les
consignes de sécurité et mais sauf votre
album amendement poser des questions
juridiques et comment imaginer qu un
employeur qui envoie à travers des
tâches et envoie en même temps à
l'interprète mais parce que nous
partageons beaucoup depuis la loi savary
vous savez très bien notre code du
travail prévoit l'obligation de désigner
un représentant en france parlant le
français par ailleurs le projet loi
travail propose
notamment des obligations bons pour
surmonter le problème de la langue avec
l'obligation d'avoir l'ensemble des
éléments d'aqmi